[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
something i really enjoy is watching how
aesthetics and movies change as
technology has advanced for example back
in the day they didn't have led light
bulbs and so when they made sci-fi
movies such as like 2001 the space
odyssey or alien all the little lights
they had were filament light bulbs
because they had them all over the place
and you're trying to make everything
look futuristic but each one of those
lights has to be a little vacuum sealed
glass chamber with a little tungsten
filament that you have to pump a lot of
electricity through to light up because
these days everything's all led and so
you can really pinpoint an era in which
those movies are made because there's no
leds in them because they weren't
invented yet same thing with screens
there weren't lcd panels up until the
90s in the 80s sci-fi films and 70s
sci-fi films all the screens tube tvs
but such a unique aesthetic to see
futuristic movies have tube tvs and
filament light bulbs when i saw logan in
theaters i realized we kind of had the
same issue here and it's actually going
to have a big impact on how car chases
are done in films from now on because
right now when you have a car chase and
a film all the cars are gas cars so they
sound all throaty and growly and
powerful
[Applause]
[Music]
the fast interior sounds great or ronin
or any other movie with a big car chase
scene in car chases there they look and
seem fast not because of the footage
really but because of the sound
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in a couple of years we're not going to
have gas cars we're gonna have electric
cars and that that vibe is going to
disappear from car chase scenes and i'm
wondering how hollywood is going to
handle that with their sound design for
example tesla cars they don't have a
radiator because there's no need for a
radiator there's no engine that needs an
air intake to cool itself the front of
the car is actually solid and in logan
the limo that he drives
has the same aesthetic you can see that
the front of the car is actually blocked
off to give it the look of a futuristic
electric style car
now the thing is the car they're
actually using in the movie is a gas car
and in fact later on when the front gets
knocked off you can still see the
radiator but the aesthetic they're
giving it here is very clearly trying to
look like an electric car and it takes
place in the year 2029 so it's more than
10 years from now arguably it would be
an electric car but in all the car chase
scenes they still have it making gas car
noises it's revving and rumbling and
rumbling and doing all the things that
gas cars do when it makes noise
but the aesthetic of the car the visual
design of it is that of an electric one
they're getting away with it here still
nobody's really noticing the difference
even though the car is visually designed
to look like an electric car and in a
couple years here as we start
transitioning more and more into
electric cars i'm really wondering
what's going to happen to car chase
scenes like are there just going to be a
bunch of like wines like
so like as they drive around because we
ever heard like a prius or tesla they
don't make any noise they're just like
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah just an interesting observation i
wonder where it's going to go in 10
years from now i'm going to look back at
this vlog and i'm going to see how
movies have changed for the sound design
maybe maybe car chase scenes will be
dead maybe they won't be able to do them
anymore once they're all electric they
just won't have the same punch maybe
it'll be like like cell phones in movies
these days where technically with cell
phones you can communicate instantly and
send pictures right away and they kind
of solve all your problems
[Music]
yeah yeah gopro make that quick edit
mark gopro stop
gopro cut
gopro turn off
awesome
gopro stop recording
this is what
a 9 000 pc looks like okay so check this
out so this is pretty sweet actually
it's not sweet so i set up the computer
it's running great i've got everything
plugged in like describe fugitive
computers rock and then unfortunately
though once we finally got it set up sam
kept getting a blue screen and if you're
not familiar with what that is it's
obviously just an error that windows
windows systems goes through basically
if you get a blue screen your computer's
airing and we could not figure out why
plugging in a webcam triggered it some
things you know trying to hook up the
audio just triggered it and we were just
getting random blue screens obviously
the system is no use to us if it doesn't
works blue screens
my brand new computer blue screen what
is going on and a blue screen again and
a blue screen again and a blue screen
again and i was just like i had to hit
him up he said guys bad news
computer's blue screen it's crashing
every single time i plug in like
anything to the motherboard like
anything in the usb it's crashing it's
blue screening it's pretty bad they're
like check this out they're like okay
like download this like little app this
little application run this like okay so
i like literally they just send me a
link and it's like a one megabyte file
and i open it up
and suddenly connects my computer to
their tech support and like suddenly my
they start moving my mouse around like
it's screen sharing and it's like whoa
whoa whoa whoa and they like within like
30 seconds of like talking to them
they're already controlling the computer
and running diagnostics on it and like
figuring out
like everything that happened looking at
crash logs everything and i'm just like
whoa okay uh and so i decided to like
step away from 15 minutes they're like
yeah yeah come back in a bit we'll take
a look and see what's up and i come back
15 minutes later actually simple issue i
just got to update the firmware on the
bio they basically have to update the
bios on the motherboard i'm like oh it's
pretty easy and uh yeah you want me to
do it for you or do you want yeah do for
me and they're like okay they just do a
couple more things they tell me to click
on one thing on the computer
restarts and it's all working yeah it's
super easy it's kind of it's cool i
guess i've talked with people online
i've chatted with tech supporter called
tech support i've done all that stuff
but i've never clicked on something and
literally had tech support take over the
computer immediately and run diagnostics
and fix everything within like a few
minutes of talking to him about that
it's kind of blowing my mind i mean i
had no idea what the issue was they were
able to figure it out in like two
seconds that's perfect everything is
butter smooth no issues didn't have to
send it back didn't have to do anything
just took a few minutes one little
update i'm pretty i'm pretty impressed
all right guys we put open uh we put up
a new video today and we're gonna show
you a few of the comments the most
wholesome and we're gonna delete all the
ones we don't like those sigma lenses
make a huge difference looking great
thanks sigma sam o's always a success to
sigma so good man sad it won't get a ton
of views
i like that one he's just so brutally
honest like what is that but it's so
good man
youtubers some people who actually put
time into their videos don't do well
look at this guy being positive about it
then let's give it a like and share it
on our profiles yeah i love these guys
and what they do in liking and sharing
it's the least i could do for the videos
they are making sami
just aren't the super talented directors
that a lot of people seem to deal with
that idealize
whilst
unbeknownst
[Laughter]
i find myself constantly disappointed by
their territory and they just really
haven't evolved
and there's plenty of way more
entertaining channels out there so it's
not like they deserve millions and
millions of views anyways
ouch oh it felt like something that came
up within a few minutes uh it took a few
hours to take a few hours
not only do youtube algorithms favor
clickbait gamers but so do most youtube
viewers if those gaming channels you're
talking about try to make something more
interesting or cinematic even for a
special
even for a special one people flip them
out
how about this one that's probably
because corridor digital doesn't do the
content they used to make and in my
opinion that's a bad thing too now
you're right we haven't evolved as
directors but we don't make the content
we used to make just love your work but
please do a video on a game called
quantum break no okay
thanks this was way better than lifeline
this looked a lot more polished a lot
more like real films than lifeline and
you guys had a lot less money and time
to make it
actually technically on a permanent
basis we had more time to make this in
lifeline yeah significantly more don't
add the black parts to the video just
upload it in twenty one sorry that's
that's a youtube problem if they allowed
us to put end cards on 21.9 formats then
we would but we can't you can only put
end cards on 16 9 formats and we've told
them three times that yeah we've
mentioned this two people who work at
youtube many times now
yeah youtube's stupid we all know it do
i really have to watch this i like this
way more than lifeline original and
feels way more corridor digital while
maintaining a very high cinematic
quality is this flubber no
how are all of your videos not viral
they are so high quality what the
subscribe
this took a lot of time to make did it
this video was
so good it made me want to put spray
paint in my subscribe as like graffiti
corridor using my scrubs
you have to at least read it in his
voice slot look better vfx
been on the pub g video i just like it's
such like an honest comment like it's
like it's like slightly better vfx it
should be teeth paste not toothpaste
he's right he's right actually
why does lifeline have comments disabled
it
this sounds doesn't a boy version of
glados
this was great and i love to watch his
voice but it was really hard to
understand i really didn't care for it
you have to buy those sigma lenses now
best looking corridor bit i've seen this
is one of my favorite from y'all
this is so well made everything about it
screams quality content keep it up guys
i listen dude harley comments
who wants to do harley
[Laughter]
[Music]
bottom music was amazing in this wasn't
the music from uh foam right now good
job film right why is it so much better
than lifeline because we learned a lot
from shooting lifeline and are now
applying it to our videos a year later
do you have it involved as a director
here's one here's one
[Music]
i had an idea this morning about uh
it's unfortunately the fidget spinner
idea and fidget spinners aren't cool
anymore but
you know the movie speed
[Music]